we stand up to the open borders Fanatics
the radical left Democrats they're
Lawless
partisan prosecutors the prosecutors
every time I fly over a blue State I get
a subpoena
we want him before the grand jury
and we stand up to the fake news media
which is seriously bad
and on November 5th 2024 we're going to
stand up
to the corrupt political establishment
we're going to evict a totally corrupt
President Joe Biden from the White House
and we're going to finish the job that
we started the most successful
presidency
and I think as everybody in this
absolutely packed house knows I've put
everything on the line and I will never
yield I never yield
I will never be deterred I will never
stop fighting for you I didn't need this
I had a great life
people said would you do it again the
answer is yes because we're going to
make America great again we had it there
and then bad things happened
bad things happened with an election
right bad bad things happened but we're
going to make it great like never before
I really believe that with your vote we
will take back our country from these
fascists and Thugs and we will
absolutely make America great again
they've launched one hoax and Witch Hunt
after another to try and stop our
movement and thwart the will of the
American people every time you have not
even believable Witch Hunt Witch Hunt
scam hoax
it's called election interference and
they're doing the best they can with it
because who the hell would vote for them
with the policies that they have of open
borders and no voter ID
as the Durham report which just came out
proved they spied in my campaign think
of it can you imagine if it was the
other way around
they spied in my campaign and we caught
them they forged false evidence to get
illegal surveillance warrants the FBI
offered one million dollars for a
fictitious dossier written by a foreign
spy to try to frame me for treason there
was now they're trying to do it again
these people don't stop and they're bad
and we have to get rid of them we have
to get rid of them fast
they put our country through hell
and they knew it was all a lie the
entire time they knew it was a lie the
ridiculous and baseless indictment of Me
by the Biden administration's weaponized
Department of Injustice
we'll go down as among the most horrific
abuses of power in the history of our
country many people have said that
Democrats have even said it this vicious
persecution is a travesty of Justice
you're watching Joe Briden job I think
of it Biden is trying to jail his
leading political opponent an opponent
that's beating him by a lot in the polls
just like they do in stalinist Russia or
communist China no different
we're really winning big we're winning
by everywhere beating the hell out of
the Republicans and we're beating the
hell out of Joe Biden that's why they're
doing it if I wasn't let me tell you if
I wasn't there'd be no Witch Hunt
there'd be no indictment
if I was losing we're winning by a lot
against the Democrats if I were losing
you know they're the party of
disinformation they say oh oh we want to
run against Trump we want to run so
badly against Trump we won the first
time and that we did better the second
time that we did the first time we won
by many millions of more votes much
better not even close
we got the most votes ever in the
history of our country and today we're
more popular than we were
in 2020 we're going to get numbers that
are absolutely incredible
federal law enforcement
should never have been involved in this
matter
but they got involved
and we just can't let that happen they
got involved with Twitter they got
involved with Facebook
there's never been anything like it in
the history of our country we've never
done like this
and the division is so bad because what
they do is so bad
and our people are angry and they just
keep doing it and sometimes you need
strength you have to have strength more
than just normal strength and we have to
get a change because we're not going to
have a country left remember I used to
campaign and I'd say that we're going to
end up being Venezuela on steroids and
that's exactly what's happening to our
country our country is going to hell